ja der heutigen letzten Vorlesung geht
es um die Anthropologie der virtuellen
Realität das ist das Thema
und wir geben ein Rückblick eine
Zusammenfassung und wir machen
abschließend ein Quiz ich habe gestern
spät abends noch die letzten Quizfragen
draufgestellt wir haben jetzt 13 Fragen
und die wollen wir gemeinsam uns
überlegen
zu Anthropologie der virtuellen Realität
wir haben ein paar fragen inwiefern kann
der Menschen virtualisiert werden
was auch immer jetzt das bedeutet
inwiefern ist die Praxis des
virtualisierens menschlich mal These ist
es sollten nicht zu sehen die erste
Frage stellen zu mir die zweite die ist
eigentlich anthropologisch interessant
die erste Frage hingegen wie der Mensch
virtualisiert werden kann und viele
Denker gehen davon aus dass das geht die
wird im Rahmen des Trans Humanismus
behandelt
Transhumanismus vielleicht haben Sie
schon mal gehört was steckt da drin dran
hinüber Jenseits und Humanismus als eine
Position die auf den Menschen bezogen
also eine übergangstheorie des Menschen
eine ja
transformative Konzeption des Menschen
und vielleicht kennen Sie diesen
ein ganz begnadeter man muss schon sagen
genialer Ingenieur Erfinder er hat zum
Beispiel die CO2 reading machine
gefunden die sehbehinderten Menschen es
erlaubte drucktexte in akustische
Signale zu umzuwandeln das war natürlich
eine Revolution und sie kennen
vielleicht die sind deshalb die Kurzwahl
sind vielleicht kennen sie hat auch auf
dem akustischen Bereich sehr viel
geleistet seine Eltern waren natürlich
Künstler sein Vater war Dirigent ne also
von nichts kommt nichts ja aber also das
soll seine Leistung gar nicht mehr also
war unglaublich er ist unglaublich
befähigt im
ja Ingenieursbereich im
erfindungsbereich
und Gründe das sogar auch die
singularity University ja 2008 was heißt
jetzt singularity die Trailer ist
natürlich Wikipedia
singularity heißt das wird jetzt gleich
genauer sehen dass ein Zustand entsteht
durch technologischen Fortschritt in dem
etwas ganz Neues passiert etwas was
vergleichbar ist mit einer Revolution
der urknallt zum Beispiel ist eine
Singularität also der energieren durch
technologische Entwicklung durch die
Verstärkung gegenseitiger Prozesse
entsteht was ganz Neues was so davor
noch nicht existierte es gibt sogar auch
ja transhumanistinnen die sich diesen
Logo versehen
das ist wieder die Beschreibung
Wikipedia
eine philosophische denke Richtung die
die Grenzen menschlicher Möglichkeiten
sei es intellektuell physisch oder
psychisch durch den Einsatz
technologische Verfahren erweitern will
erweitern oder vielleicht auch
revolutionieren das muss man auch
dahingestellt sein lassen interessant
Werte der Menschheit werden als
Verpflichtung zur Fortschritt angesehen
der Transhumanismus hat also durchaus
eine ja humanistische grundrendenz er
möchte den Menschen verbessern er möchte
den Menschen auch befreien von seinem
sterblichen Körper ja das sind alles
Hindernisse und wenn Sie das jetzt mal
anschauen diese Tendenz Verbesserung
Optimierung
Loslösung von materiellen Grenzen dann
könnte man auf den Gedanken kommen dass
das eine Form von Virtualisierung des
Menschen ist dass der transsilvanismus
einen virtuellen Menschen zeigen möchte
der real ist aber der eben nicht mehr
der eigentlich biologische Mensch ist
sondern der eben sich bloß gelöst hat
von seiner endlichen Einschränkung des
Körpers und genau so sehen das auch
Transmann ist der Art von Spray Kurzwahl
dass sie eine virtuelle Existenz des
Menschen konzipieren wird indem wir
befreit sind und zu neuen Möglichkeiten
in der Lage sind sie nennen sich an
meine fünf definitionspunkte von
virtuelle Realität ob das geht ist
natürlich eine andere Frage wir schauen
uns jetzt gemeinsam ein wenig finde sehr
sehr
treffendes kurzes Video von ARTE anarte
über Rekordzeit und wir wollen uns dabei
folgende Fragen stellen was versteht
Kurzwahl unter virtuelle Realität er
verwendet den Begriff ganz kurz am
Anfang achten Sie gut drauf
weitere Frage welche Anthropologie liegt
dem Transhumanismus des
Durchschnitts von Ray kurz weil zugrunde
inwiefern ist der Transhumanismus eine
philosophische Position diese Frage
wollen wir uns jetzt hier genauer
stellen wir schauen uns das Video jetzt
gemeinsam an und diskutieren danach über
diese Fragen machen Sie sich gerne
Notizen Video geht so ca 10 Minuten und
danach sammeln wir unsere wichtigsten
Erkenntnisse
ja wir haben uns Gedanken gemacht zu
als Motivation
über Ray kurzweils Transhumanismus unter
dem Gesichtspunkt der virtuellen
Realität das ist ja unser Bezug und wir
haben gesehen er verwendet zumindest in
dem Interview und in diesem kleinen
Reportage Virtualität im Sinne von
realistischer Simulation
wir haben auch gesehen dass er ein
Transhumanismus verfolgt der das Ziel
hat den Menschen zu verbessern
und wir können uns fragen ob die
Verbesserung des Menschen im Sinne
seiner Virtualisierung zu verstehen ist
ein wichtiger Begriff der bei ihrem
Zentrum steht ist der Begriff der
Singularität wir haben gehört der wird
häufig Anleihe an physikalische Begriffe
verwendet der Urknall ist eine
Singularität er sagt natürlich auch die
Evolution des Menschen Zukunft wird zu
einer Singularität führen die genau
datierbar ist nämlich auf das Jahr 2045
so sieht es titelbild Aus achten Sie mal
auf den Untertitel der ist nämlich hier
wichtiger wenn humans Trance wenn die
Menschheit wenn Menschen die Biologie
überschreiten Trans Humanismus und
transgendere beschreiben wie ist jetzt
diese Überschreitung zu verstehen das
müssen wir uns jetzt fragen schauen sie
mal auf das Titelbild wir sehen ein
Gehirn was künstlich nachgebildet ist ja
die Form ist dasselbe diese ganzen
verschlungen aber hier sind Schaltkreis
ja technische
Phänomene integriert oder es ist
künstlich realisiert
künstliche Simulation muss man sich
jetzt fragen weil ja die Form des selbe
ist
jetzt müssen wir uns aber mal seine
eigentliche these anschauen und zwar ist
es die These des exponentiellen
Wachstums des
Computers wir sehen hier eine Zeitlinie
und wir sehen hier
2045 ist hier und hier sehen wir
irgendwie die Rechenleistung links auf
der Y-Achse die Kalkulation pro Sekunde
pro Dollar also auch ökonomisch
ökonomischer Quotient
und die Rechenpower pro Sekunde pro
Dollar wird im Jahr 2045 so groß sein
wie die rechenauer aller menschliche
Gehirne zusammen ein Dollar pro Sekunde
habe ich sozusagen
die Leistung aller menschlichen Gehirne
hat noch Zeit Aspekt auch noch drin alle
menschliche Gehirne muss man sich fragen
die zurzeit existieren oder die jemals
existiert hat wahrscheinlich die Zeit
existieren also mehrere Milliarden
menschlichen Gehirne kann ich diese
Rechenpower kann ich pro Dollar bekommen
mit einem Chip für einen Dollar kriege
ich diese Leistung
jetzt muss man sich natürlich fragen ist
die Rechnung Power aller menschliche
Kerne so groß
zusammengeschaltet reinschaltung
Parallelschaltung bringt es uns
irgendwas
sie sehen analogisiert das ganz stark
mit technischen Phänomen
jedenfalls ist das glaube ich
unbestritten hier kann das schon mal
nämlich zeigen dass bis zum Jahr 2000
die Rechenpower Entwicklung über die
Zeit hinweg auf einer exponentiellen
Kunden liegt 17 wunderbar diese Burg
gezeichnete Kurve und wenn man jetzt mal
hier so weitergeht dann kann man auch
nicht weiter so steil ansteigt kann man
sich natürlich denken wenn das so
weitergeht dann kann er irgendwann mal
was ganz Neues hervor
dann kann es zu einer Singularität
kommen
und jetzt bringt er hier eine Definition
change
so deep that human live University
transform ein technischer Fortschritt
der dazu führt dass menschliches Leben
menschliches Leben ist
nun umkehrbar
transformiert
distopien this apoquille transform the
concepts
to give meaning to all lines or business
models to the cycle of human live
including death it's
Humanismus sei weder eine Utopie noch
eine Dystopie sondern es sei ein Techno
Realismus das sagt so wird es einfach
sein da müssen wir gar nicht groß
utopisch sein das ist der Weg der wird
im Jahr 2045 erreicht werden
an das Standing der singularity will
Alter operspective on the significence
of our past and the remifications for
our future für Trudy and the stand it in
herley changes once view of life in
general und particular live someone
Larry also wir müssen sagt ihr immer
diese Zukunftsprognose Perspektive die
realistisch ist die technologisch ist
die nicht dystopisch ist wie ready
Player one die nicht utopisch ist wie
irgendwas anderes immer berücksichtigen
das müssen wir sagen für uns erleben mal
im Blick behalten diese Perspektive das
singularity will represente
communication of the merge auf thinking
Systems technology resulting in the
world is the human but the trance roots
der will be notesion
human
physical
reality jetzt haben wir hier den Begriff
genannt bekommen nachdem wir immer
gesucht haben virtuelle Realität was
sagt der jetzt hier rüber
es geht also um eine Verschmelzung von
unserer biologischen und unsere
technologischen Existenz und das führt
zu einer Welt die immer noch menschlich
ist aber unsere biologischen
Wurzeln unsere biologische Evolution
überschreitet er spricht von einer
Vermischung von biologische Evolution
und technologische genau genommen sagte
im Jahr 2045 wird die biologische
Evolution abgelöst durch technologische
Reaktion oder anders gesagt die
biologische Evolution bringt hervor aus
sich eine technologische Revolution
Evolution die Menschheit ist so
biologisch clever geworden dass sie sich
selbst übersteigt und durch
Selbstoptimierung die Evolution selbst
in die Hand nimmt und nicht mehr
irgendwelchen Prinzipien unterliegt die
ihr unverfügbar sind und bislang ist es
eben so wir wissen nicht wohin uns die
Evolution treibt sie hat uns zu einem
sehr bewussten Zustand gebracht und
jetzt müssen wir schauen dass wir sie
noch zu guten linken und nicht irgendwie
uns auf blinde Mechanismen verlassen die
da im Hintergrund werkeln und gar nicht
intentional wäre können sie wissen ja
die Evolution sagen viele ist ja gar
nicht teleologisch zielgerichtet
sie ist ja nicht irgendwie so dass sie
auf ein bestimmtes Ziel hinführt
deswegen müssen wir unser Schicksal
selbst in die Hand nehmen sind die
Evolution und jetzt müssen wir schauen
was sagt jetzt über virtuelle Realität
wie bestimmte den Begriff hier sitzt die
erste Definition die in diesem Video war
recht kurz und schwammig es wird
in der Zeit nach der Singularität nach
2045 wird es keine Unterscheidung mehr
geben zwischen Mensch und Maschine
zwischen physischer und virtueller
Realität
okay also er sagt jetzt
virtuelle Realität nimmt ja auf die
Seite der Maschine ja der Künstlichkeit
und er sagt es gibt jetzt hier nicht
eine Ablösung sondern eine Aufhebung des
Unterschieds das heißt
maschinell künstliche Prozesse werden
selbst zu unserer zweiten Natur unsere
Natur wird geprägt wesentlich das was
uns als Menschen aus wird
vermischt kombiniert sein durch
biologische Aspekte aber auch durch
technologische Aspekte durch was er sagt
virtuelle Aspekte
wir können da gar nicht nur
unterscheiden das ist die verschmelzunge
müssen uns genau vorstellen genau
überlegen wie man sich das vorstellen
kann
jetzt bringe ich Ihnen ein Beispiel ihr
das zeigt er geht auf die
Nanotechnologie ein ist auch der
kommende Trend also das sind die Clients
also kleine Teile also mikroskopische
Teile die eben es erlaubt und unser
Körper einzutringen auch sonstige Dinge
vorzunehmen und uns zu manipulieren weil
wir zu auf Bereiche hineinkommen in die
wir normalerweise nicht hineinkommen
weil wir nicht dieses Skala erreichen
diese Planung technology
the design of Bots also kleinste
Bots kleinste Werkzeuge kleinste Roboter
kleinsten robots design at the
mallekülern auf molekulare Basis
Magazine million
chemical red blood Sense nanobot will
have mirrored rolls with the human body
including reversing human aging
extended or ready have been completed
through Biotechnologie
er will also nicht nur Maschinen äh
Ingenieurs mäßig optimieren
das Leben den Menschen und das kann wenn
es nicht durch Biotechnologie schon
möglich ist noch zusätzlich durch
Nanobots erreicht wird also kleinste
Roboter drehen unser Körper ein durch
die Blutbahn kommen ins Gehirn
manipulieren da was rum und verändern
unsere Lebensdauer sie machen uns Jünger
indem sie Prozesse der Alterung
rückgängig machen systematisch ja und
zwar eben wenn wir ganz viele solcher
nanopods in uns hineinlassen ja
sie haben ganz viele Rollen zu spielen
nanoportional interact with Biologie
experience by creating virtual reality
from within
also es ist wieder der Gedanke virtuelle
Realität wird vermischt oder wird
aufeinander bezogen wird vermischt mit
dem biologisch also Virtual Reality was
versteht jetzt darunter er versteht
darunter Nanotechnologie also künstliche
Intelligenz die selbst
mit unserem biologischen Wesen
verschwinden verschmilzt und sind
kooperierter das versteht er unter
virtual real
ist natürlich nicht unser Begriff wir
können das einfach künstliche
künstliche
Verbesserung des Menschen nennen er
nennt es virtual reality
ich würde einfach sagen dass technische
Optimierung
wobei natürlich diese Nano Funktion
übernehmen die bis dahin nur biologische
Phänomen
und insofern kann man wieder fragen ob
es nicht doch auf unseren Begriff passt
wird der teleologisch durch künstliche
Instrumente derselbe Zweck realisiert
den wir auch so realisieren konnten
also ist es ist eine ersetzungsrelation
der gewissen Hinsicht schon und es ist
auch nicht nur Simulation die nanobot
simulieren ja nicht nur das was unser
Körper so schon macht sein sie
realisieren es auf neue weiß und es
ergeben sich neue Möglichkeiten
so gesehen wird es wieder in unser
System passen
Künstlichkeit ich würde trotzdem nicht
sagen dass es virtuelle Realität nach
unseren Begriffen ist weil es einfach
nur eine technologische
Verbesserung darstellt so wie wir eben
von der Dampf vom Dampf paradig mal zum
elektronischen elektrischen paradigment
gekommen sind auf dieser Ebene seht ist
ich sehe das jetzt nicht auf dieser
Ebene wie wir bisher Virtualität
bestimmt haben aber spannende Thematik
auf jeden Fall
und jetzt möchte ich zusammenfassen wie
man diesen Transhumanismus
kategorisieren kann der Transhumanismus
ist auf jeden Fall spekulativen zieht
sich auf die Zukunft
er sagt bispo quill are you that within
several decades Information Base
technologies will in plumpers all human
knowledge and professioncy ultimatey
including
recognition powers
Problems kills and emotional
challengeance of the human
also musste Erkennung sagte schon in
diesem Buch wird ganz wichtig sein und
sogar emotionale Intelligenz wird durch
musste Erkennung möglich sind natürlich
Emotionen sind auch Muster ich kann aus
ihrem Gesicht die Emotion erkennen ich
habe das evolutionär in mir drin wir
alle haben das in uns drin und es ist
ein Muster ich kann anhand des
Verhältnisses ihre Augen zum Mund und
anderen scheinbar unmerkliche Dinge das
musste ihre momentan emotional
Verfasstheit erschließen manchmal irre
ich mich darin da deutlich ihren
Gesichtsausdruck falsch das heißt
Interpretation spielt auch eine Rolle
aber prinzipiell kann ich lachen von von
Aggression unterscheiden und warum
sollte das nicht auch eine KI können sie
nur Muster wir füttern die KI mit ganz
vielen menschlichen Gesichtern wir leben
die wir zeigen diese Gesichter und
anhand dieser Datenbasis kann das System
wenn es nur viele solche Gesichter
einließ doch irgendwann sein musste
der Transhumanismus ist Techno
optimistisch und progressiv
als er möchte die Menschheit verbessern
also impressive respects the brain
suffers from the real limitations
it's massive paralytices
operating simulation
is extrem
[Musik]
sind zu engstirnig die haben wir
Scheuklappe die schauen immer drauf
Problem und sehen nicht das gesamte
wohin sich das gesamte entwickeln kann
das ist alles für einen visionären
Zugang zum Menschen und seine Technik
und jetzt kommt ein ganz entscheidende
Passage wo seine eigene ja
Intention liegt dir auch natürlich mit
virtuelle Realität verbindet das
singularity
limitations logical Party
wir müssen keine Vitamin Pillen
einwerfen um länger zu leben
difference statement from saying ribble
live
bei the end of the century the new
trillions of thrillend of times
human intelligence
das sind alles Zukunftsaussagen
unsere Sterblichkeit wird in unseren
Händen liegen das heißt wir müssen nicht
unbedingt unsterblich sein aber wir
können bestimmen wie lange leben 1700
Jahre so lange Spaß macht ja wenn es uns
irgendwann langweilig wird immer alles
schon zehnmal gesehen haben dann können
wir sagen system of schalt mich aus aber
vielleicht werde ich auch später mal
wieder erweckt ja von einem unsere
Nachkommen der denkt ach dieser Vorfahre
da der scheint ganz interessant zu sein
guck mal wiederbeleben ja so das ist
seine Aussage
ja
jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen ist
das wirklich angemessen
ich möchte ihm zum Schluss noch in der
heutigen ersten Sitzung sein
Evolutionsmodell vorstellen dieses Buch
ist also sehr empfehlenswert zu lesen
ist aber auch unglaublich spekulativ und
fast schon dramaturgisch ausgearbeitet
weil sie Szene hat sechs Epochen und die
unterste Epoche ist die alabasalste
Evolution
wo nämlich physikalisch und
chemikalische Prozesse sich in atomaren
Strukturen ordnen dann kommt die DNA
dann kommt die zweite Epoche des die
biologische nicht mehr die physikalische
Evolution dann kommt die Gehirn
Evolution in neuronale musterwert
erzeugt dann
das sind wir gerade Epoche 4 da hat im
reagiert Technologie
Informationen hardware software design
sind so unsere Zeit bald aber kommt
Epoche 5
weil technology Masters the matrix of
biology including human intelligence
neuronale Netze dieser Ausdruck
künstlichen neuronale Netze ist
natürlich dem Gehirn nachempfunden es
ist streng genommen keine Simulation
aber es ist eine Analogie eine gewisse
Orientierung daran das heißt wir
orientieren uns in der Technologie an
der Biologie versuchen die ja was jetzt
zu simulieren so virtualisieren er würde
sagen durch die Technologie
virtualisieren wird die Biologie das
Verhältnis zwischen Biologie und
Technologie ist aus der Perspektive
Distanz Humanismus die der Virtualität
der Virtualisierung
es heißt jetzt aber nicht dass wir
unbedingt unsere biologische Realität
dadurch aufgeben sondern dass sie
verschmelzen sind zwei Bereiche
also dann kommt in Epoche 5 technology
intelligence
of biology auch integrade into the human
technology
und jetzt ist damit noch nicht genug er
setzt den noch eins drauf wir haben noch
eine sechste Woche nämlich die Universe
wake up patterns of metal and energy in
the universe satrated intelligent
process
ja also die menschliche Intelligenz ist
in der sechsten Epoche nicht mehr
gebunden an
Materie an Technologien Chips sondern
sie verteilt sich im ganzen Universums
sie wird in die Energie selbst
hineingewirkt
konsequenter geht natürlich diese
Spekulation nicht mehr ja menschlich
Intelligenz ist überall weil sie
prinzipiell in Materie eindringen kann
und Materie ist ja wie wir wissen auch
überall oder auch nicht das heißt unsere
Grenzen die uns körperlich gesetzt sind
werden der sechsten Epoche gänzlich
aufgehoben
ja seien Sie gespannt was da noch auf
uns zukommt
aber trotzdem ist es ja lesenswert es
liest sich trotzdem wie ein
futuristischer Roma und für mich hat es
trotz allem etwas stark utopischisches
weil er sagten dass das alles so positiv
sich entwickelt ja er sieht das ja nur
positiv er hat ein ganz klaren Techno
Optimismus und das ist nicht ohne
weiteres so zu akzeptieren aus
philosophische Perspektive bei wer sagt
denn dass die Technologie nicht auch zu
schlechten führen kann das kann erstmal
alleine aufgrund von
und funktionaler
Problematik sein sie wissen die neuesten
Expertin Experten über
Weltuntergangsszenarien sagen die größte
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass die Menschheit
zugrunde geht liegt nicht in
Naturkatastrophen oder atomkriegen
sondern im künstliche Intelligenz das
ist die Nummer eins der Expertin
Experten
was
weltuntergangsgründe an künstlichen
Intelligenz kann man sich natürlich
fragen was ist der Grund für die
Weltuntergang sagen aber nur mit einer
Wahrscheinlichkeit von zwei Prozent also
keine Sorge jetzt kann man sich fragen
gibt zwei Möglichkeiten entweder weil
die künstliche Intelligenz so
intelligent ist und wie bei Terminator
super Intelligenzen erzeugt die uns
Menschheit abschafft ich glaube das
meinen die nicht sind die meint er wird
delegieren immer mehr
verantwortungsvolle
Aktionen an die künstlichen Intelligenz
und durch Fehler oder sonstige
unvorhersehbare Ereignisse
wendet sich das gegen uns selbst wir
haben die ganze Technik nicht mehr in
der Hand und das Ruder läuft uns sehr
aus der Hand ja so wie der
Zauberlehrling so was ja also irgendwie
wir werden nicht mehr her der
Technologie sowas ist glaube ich ihr
damit zu machen also warum muss ich das
so positiv entwickeln diese kritische
Perspektive fehlt völlig ja genauso wird
nicht debattiert wie man ja auch
künstliche Intelligenz oder Technik zum
Schlechten gebrauchen kann er sich
schlecht entwickeln sondern wir können
Sie natürlich auch schlecht gebrauchen
wer sagt uns das dadurch nicht
irgendwelche Menschen manipuliert werden
in einer Weise die vielleicht auch der
Würde des Menschen der spricht
ja das überspringe ich ein bisschen also
das ist die fünf Epoche the Merch auf
human technologische beziehungens das
ist jetzt bald
und die singularity will
come age old human problemity
alles Positive
das ist aber nicht ohne weiteres
einsichtig und die Epoche 6 das
Universum erwacht in die aftermath im
Nachgang der Singularität intelligence
also abgeleitet sein biologischen
Wurzeln wenn ich jemanden Prange
technological
begin to saturate the matter energy
digital
recognizing matter and energy to private
optional level of computation to spread
out for it Origin
Aufbruch in neuwelt
ja das ist also ziemlich spekulativ ich
möchte auch noch mal hier ein Punkt
vorstellen der wieder auf die virtuelle
Realität eingeht dann nennt diesen
Begriff von manchen Stellen es wird
schon reality from with in the nerval
Systems becomes competitive wo es real
reality in Trumps of Resolution in
believer billity orix will increasing
take place in Virgin Bayerns in virtual
reality we can be a different persons
physically and emotion
effekton Partner will be able to select
and different body for you than you
might select for yourself in weißes
okay also wie verstehen Sie jetzt hier
virtuelle Realität
unterscheidet Virtual Reality von Real
reality als erscheint Virtual Reality
als
künstliche Phänomene zu verstehen die
dieselben Leistungen vollziehen wie
unsere biologisch natürliche Umwelt also
Virtual Reality ist für ihn letztendlich
computer generierte Technologie
technologische
Theologie technologische Effizienz
verbesserungs
wir haben gesehen nach unseren Begriffen
das ist noch nicht der Fall sind von
virtuelle Realität weil wir nach unseren
Begriffen Virtual Reality nie von Real
reality unterscheiden nach unseren
Begriffen ist wird virtuelle Realität
eine Form von Realität so wie es
physische mentale Realität gibt ja also
sie sehen begrifflich ist es auch eine
anderen Ebene angesiedelt wir können
Virtual Reality nach seiner
Begrifflichkeit erklären als
Künstlichkeit künstliche
effizienztechnologische
Realisierung von biologischen Vorgaben
okay also er sagt unsere Erfahrungen
wird sich in virtuellen Umgebungen
verabschieden
hat noch ein Buch geschrieben die age of
spiritual machines when Computers exceed
human intelligence
geistige Maschine haben die
Selbstbewusstsein natürlich wieder
hochgradig spekulativ werden
der wohnt be mortality bei DN of the
twenty first
centraliens that we have
you take advantage of the twenty first
century pray praying technology that
also schon die Dichte haben unsere
physische Existenz
für intensheet aus selfs and to all
computational technology identity will
base on our rolling my
we will be Software Nord
wieder zukunftsaussage will be
wir werden nur noch in Form von Software
existieren und nicht in Form von
Hardware warum weil die Hardware am Ende
immer kaputt geht kennen sie alle wenn
wieder der Prozesse durchgebrannt ist
haben sie hoffentlich Ihre Daten
gesichert in der Cloud ja
das was unsere Identität ausmacht ist
unsere mein Fall unsere mentalen
Eigenschaften und die können wir sagen
er prinzipiell von unserem Körper lösen
nämlich digitalisieren die klaut oder wo
auch immer hochladen
es ist Software
wie dependent on the survival of
immer schön die Festplatte löschen und
dann rotieren we transfer them at least
we want to kee so true we boat throw our
mindfilet aus self to the latest
Personal
ganz interessant hier er spricht hier
von der Essenz unserer Identität
das was uns eigentlich aus was uns
personale Identität ausmachen was uns zu
uns macht sagt er ist nicht unser Körper
nicht die Harke sondern unsere Software
unsere mentalen Eigenschaften unsere
Erinnerung das ist sogenannte
bewusstseinskriterium es geht zurück auf
John Lock 18 Jahrhundert der hat das
schon behauptet unsere Identität besteht
nicht in unserem organischen Körper wir
sind wesentlich nicht Menschen weil
Menschen werden definiert über ihren
biologischen Körper
wir sind auch nicht materieansammlungen
weil wir uns häufig austauschen und
Teile verlieren sehr schlimm wenn unsere
Identität in den Zusammensetzung unseres
Körpers zum jetzigen Zustand befindet
dann wären wir nicht mehr dieselben wie
wir waren vor 20 Jahren oder ich weiß
nicht wie lange und in zehn Jahren auch
nicht mehr sondern wir sind das was
unser Bewusstsein
bewusstseinsidentität ist das diejenige
was uns zu uns macht und das nimmt er
auch und er führt es fort konsequent in
die technologische Dimension nämlich die
Software
ganz interessant auch noch hier
wir können
Dinge von uns sagt er wegwerfen
und wir können entscheiden was wir von
uns behalten so wäre auch von seinem
Vater sprach dass er ihn irgendwie
konstruieren möchte so können wir
bestimmen was von uns wollen wir noch
weiterhin beibehalten und was nicht
welchen Charakter zu welcher Erinnerung
möchte ich beibehalten und was lasse ich
lieber bleiben ja so wie sie wenn sie
ein Datenarchiv haben von sich auf der
Festplatte und der Computer muss
gewechselt werden sie brauchen einmal
Festplatte entscheiden können welche
Fotos nehme ich noch mit und welche
löscht die Fotos auf den ich mir nicht
zu gefallen
und die Fotos auf denen ich mit einer
Person zu sehen bin die mir heute nicht
mehr so gefällt die lösche ich
manipulieren meine eigene Geschichte
machen wir natürlich immer wir
manipulieren immer unsere eigene
Geschichte durch selektive Warnung
Detektives erinnern durch unterbewusstes
verdrängen aber das ist noch mal eine
Stärke eine höhere Stufe ja das ist
wirklich ontologisch weil es gibt dann
diese Teile von uns nicht mehr die wir
gelöscht haben die sind nicht mehr
Bestandteil unserer
mentalen ja das heißt entwirft eine
Anthropologie des Computers
eine ganz spannende Theorie willheft
reload und old backup copy and be Dooms
to repeat past wenn wir nämlich
aufpassen und regelmäßige Backups machen
also speichern dann kann es sein dass
wir wieder zurückfallen auf einen
vorherigen Zustand und unser Leben noch
leben müssen sie kennen das alle wenn
Sie an einer Abschlussarbeit schreiben
und die neueste Version geht ihn
verloren haben sie nur noch eine ältere
Version und genauso sagte es ist auch
mit unserem Leben wenn wir aufpassen ich
regelmäßig Updates machen kann es sein
wir müssen noch mal neu beginnen vor
fünf Jahren ja also starke Analogie
Computer startet oder extensions of iron
Mainz and the will and up extendings are
already at integriert
wenn das zentral spiritual machines of
the twenty first centralobian even more
intimateation das sagt Computer werden
immer lebensweltliche relevant zu mal
dann wenn sie geistige Fähigkeiten
kommen ich bezweifelte ich glaube
Computer können prinzipiell keine
geistigen Eigenschaften erlangen da muss
man natürlich noch genau das begründen
ja wir denke ich machen sie mal Schluss
wir machen jetzt eine kleine
Mittagspause bis halb eins und setzen
dann die Debatte vor Ort wenn es um die
Frage nach der Rolle von virtuellen
Körper geht das ist sicherlich auch
entspanntes Team